a Connecticut man is claiming
self-defense in the death of a hotel
worker while he was on a family vacation
in the Caribbean Scot Hapgood is charged
with killing Kenny Mitchell of the
Caribbean island of Anguilla
earlier this month spokesman for Hapgood
says he was trying to protect his family
when Mitchell attacked him without
warning when'll ng is here with the
latest details molla good morning good
morning Nora a police spokesman told The
Associated Press that hapgoods young
daughters were in the hotel room when
Kenny Mitchell was killed investigators
have not reported a motive for his death
and in Greenland officials say they're
struggling to find answers to the many
questions in this case Anguilla's Police
Department says officers were called to
investigate Kenny Mitchell's death
shortly after 4:00 p.m. on April 13th
the 27 year old father worked at a
luxury resort on the islands West End an
autopsy report shows he was beaten and
choked to death three days later police
charged Scott Hapgood with manslaughter
the 44 year old from Connecticut was
vacationing on the island with his
family and staying at the hotel where
Mitchell was allegedly employed as a
maintenance worker
a spokeswoman for hapgoods says the
worker showed up unannounced in uniform
at the hotel room claiming he was there
to fix a broken sink before carrying out
his sudden violent attack on the family
she alleges he was armed and demanding
money
Mitchell's uncle Victor says that's not
true we'll get anybody's program
Hapgood was originally denied bail from
prison but later released on a 74
thousand dollar bond following an appeal
from his attorney local reports say many
angry lands are angry and demanding
Hapgood returned to the island to face
justice
[Music]
the British territory of around 15,000
people in the Caribbean often attracts
wealthy vacationers on social-media
Anguilla's former head of tourism urged
residents not to allow the case to
tarnish the islands reputation we remain
resolute and forming a belief that we
are proud strong and we continue to
welcome visitors to our shoes well
Hapgood is a financial adviser he's due
back in court in Anguilla and August his
attorney on the island told a local
newspaper that he has every intention to
return to Anguilla to clear his name the
reports say that Hapgood had never
previously been charged with a crime
guys it's a very bizarre story it is a
lot of angry people on that island wanna
give you the time yeah and a lot of
questions thank you good to have you at
the table it's good to be here look the
same as you do on TV nice to hear it
better in person
thank you